vite c'est dur pour toi matthew pas dit
la vérité moi deux choses là ce que toi
tu as eu des hauts et des bas m'ont
battu à brême et moi je vais vous dire
parce qu'encore une fois pardon mais
ceux qui parlent sont ceux qui savent
pas d'abord ce que tu dis sur
l'entreprise s'est pas dû à la télé dans
les entreprises et chez france télécom
la porte cote à 25 ans en cdi quand tu
pars tu pars avec un gros chèque c'est
pas dieu l'a terrassé l'entreprise passe
à cette adresse à y avoir et savoir de
la vie je savais que c'était dur la
célébrité et après il ya le voir mais
moi je peux te dire qu'à recommencer ce
métier je le recommence pas non c'est
vrai mathieu et pour bien sûr quoique
aux attentes bien qu'en voiture à
hauteur de minutes c'est pareil je
m'arrête de seconde la succion elle si
on devait te dire voilà la tâte un choix
à faire
j'en ferais pas du tout les mêmes ne
devrait plus être à l'antenne
c'est ce que j'aimerais genre et
j'aurais fait un métier je le dis j'aime
bien les jolies voitures et j'aurais
fait un métier pour avoir une très jolie
confort de vie peut-être monter un resto
une salle de sport et tout mais je ne
serais pas allé dans la célébrité
pourquoi si j'avais su pas parce que je
me rends compte que j'ai lu ça me
correspond pas tellement je vis ils
étaient jugés tout le temps tu es tu
critiques et tout le temps tu es tu es
tu es tu n'as pas de vie tu ne peux pas
sortir avec elle ça me fait du mal ce un
petit peu j'adore passer du temps avec
vous mais ce qui me met aujourd'hui les
inconvénients pour moi sont bien
supérieurs à ce que vous dites et
nazareth 30 à une table et tout ça côté
un peu de pognon tue là aussi moi je te
dis donc voilà non non je vous racontais
parce que donc dans quel dans quelle
entreprise
on peut être licencié en une minute sur
un sondage et bien moi j'ai eu ça moi
nrj12 et si nous regarde notre ami
vincent broussard qui était venu
directeur général et ça faisait six ans
que j'étais nrj 12 où je dis pas que tu
es un génie mais six langues et ça
marchait bien et ça marchait très bien
et un jour au mois de juin un colloque
dans son bureau et il me dit cher
mathieu je vais changer la chaîne il ya
trop de télé réalité je veux qu'elle ait
du sens tu es le symbole de ce que je ne
veux plus alors tu dégages
il savait pas que tu faisais un métier
d'image je vous jure on avait laissé le
shérif répondu non mais monsieur le
directeur il est en général je me suis
lavé séché c'est un petit peu dur ou moi
je peux changer puis jeudi il me dit
vous n'avez pas elle voulait tuer pas vu
le coup arriver bajus dit non je dois
être un peu idiot j'anime de la télé
réalité
il m'a dit de fait non je suis parti
avec 000 d'indemnités pas de prud'hommes
rien de contraire ce qu'on m'a dit si tu
attaques
ça sort a et aura toutes les chaînes à
dos ah non ça sera le monsieur
procédurier je suis parti avec 0 pas un
euro
j'avais que des cdd mais se retrouver
dans la rue le première chose que j'ai
fait si j'appelais mon pote fogiel et
lui dit qu'est ce que je fais et m'a dit
vente à bagnols je te jure que c'est
vrai et la semaine d'après ben dhia le
tunisien qui m'appellent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]